[MUSIC PLAYING]
IAN LAKE: So welcome to "Forget
the Storage Permission."
It's not often we go
to a tech conference
and get to go to a talk for
where we're specifically
going to be forgetting things.
But it's the end
of the Barbecue,
so hopefully we'll actually
learn a few new techniques
which will just
replace that knowledge
rather than totally void it out.
We'll save that one for later.
But really trying to reduce when
we actually need the storage
permission, so this
would be write and read
external storage.
So a little bit about myself.
I've been doing
Android development
for just about five years now.
I kind of started on my
own, but then got a job
doing it full time at Phunware
and then joined Facebook.
So I didn't fix
everything I want.
But [INAUDIBLE] a lot better.
But for this last year,
I've been working at Google
as a developer advocate, kind of
working both with the community
and with the internal
engineering teams.
Primarily, I've been focused
on an advanced Android Udacity
course.
This is online learning,
kind of taking your app
to really be production ready,
although those little things
that really make an
app that much better.
And then of course,
just recently
launched Android
development patterns
with Joanna Smith, best
practices in Android
covering a lot of the APIs
as well as the reasons why
behind some of these things.
My focus primarily has been
Android framework and Android
support library.
And we'll be talking about
a lot of those things today.
So we're going to be
forgetting things.
We're going to forget
the storage permission.
But to really forget it, we need
to know, what was it giving us
in the first place?
So let's start at the beginning.
Where can we
actually store data?
So first there's this concept
of app-specific storage space.
So as you'd expect,
these are our directories
which are specific to
your app and to each user.
Now, one important
thing about all
of these directories
that'll be covered here
is that they're all completely
emptied and destroyed
when your app is uninstalled.
So it's really easy
to say, OK, well.
I've now completely
uninstalled the app,
and now all of the
data associated with it
isn't left lingering
on my device.
There's kind of two main
types of these directories.
There's private directories
stored on internal storage.
So these are accessible via
getFileDir and getCacheDir.
So as you can
imagine, getFileDir
are for kind of actual,
real files, user data,
while getCacheDir is
more for caching files.
Say if you were to download
large images from the internet,
this would be a good
place to store them.
Because when we
run low on memory,
this space can be
cleared without actually
harming users' data.
Now, the other side of
things are these concept
of "external" directories.
And I'll use air quotes because
they're not actually external.
On many devices,
like Nexus devices,
they're actually
on the same flash
drive as the internal storage.
It's simply just a different
partition of the same space.
But in all cases, it's actually
that those external directories
are the ones that are
readable by all apps that
have the storage permissions.
So you don't necessarily want
to put sensitive information
in those folders because
they are world readable.
However, for our cases, you can
actually do a little bit more
with them.
So these come in the face of
external files directory, which
is very similar to our file
directory for user data
on this external partition.
And in KitKat, we actually
introduced the ability
to have multiple external
files directories.
So in this case, you could
have one external file
on that internal
slash external storage
and another on
like your SD card.
So this would be returned by the
pluralized form of the method.
Similarly, for our cache
directories, same type
of thing.
And then also in Lollipop,
we added external media
directories.
These are directories
where you can write files
to that are then read
by the media scanner.
So this is what
allows other apps
to get all of the images
and videos and pictures
that are in that
folder and then make
them available to other apps
via the media store API.
Now, the best part about
all of these directories
is that they don't actually
require permissions
on newer devices.
So the other directory--
which I really
want to mention also for
game developers, especially--
is the extension file
directory, the OBB directory.
This is where apps that are
larger than the 50 or now 100
megabyte limit can
store expansion files.
These are actually
shared across all users.
So if you have a huge,
large game on a tablet,
it's actually shared
across all the storage.
You're not penalized for having
the same huge app installed
multiple times.
So the other part of this, those
are app specific directories.
The next part is public storage.
So these are the permanent
files that survive
your app being uninstalled.
Now, for many
users, this actually
means that those files are
never going to be touched,
never going to be deleted,
and may be orphaned forever
because the chances of many
users actually using a file
manager or going in or
even plugging their Android
phone into a computer
are actually fairly rare.
Many more users are just
using the apps on their phone
and don't actually realize that
this public storage exists.
Now from that
perspective, again, this
is stored on kind of that
external but maybe not
external space.
It's called external.
And the root of it can be get
by getExternalStorageDirectory.
But you probably
shouldn't actually
write file so that
root directory, right?
It's like writing to C:/ or the
beginning of another directory
like, maybe not the best idea.
You can do it, but
you'd much rather,
if you were writing to this
public external storage,
use one of the directories
that we've created.
So there's one for pictures and
notifications and ring tones
and various other media
types which auto sort
into these public directories.
Now, an important
part about this
is, if you have multiple users
on the same phone, which is now
possible-- or on tablets,
which has been possible
back a number of versions--
all of the external storage
is actually sandboxed
for each user.
There's no way for your
app running as one user
to ever see data that's
in another user's
public directories.
Even though it's called public,
it's still sandbox user, right?
That's more of an SELinux
thing than anything else.
But it's actually really
important for things
like Android for Work,
where that separate user
is, of course, totally
self-contained and separate
from your private data.
So we talked about what
all these directories mean
for the storage permission.
So for those internal
directories-- the getFileDir,
getCacheDir-- those can always
be read with no permissions
whatsoever.
They're always going
to be available to you.
You can always write to them.
They're great.
And of course, they're
auto cleaned up
when your app's installed.
So it's really nice for users.
Now, the external app-specific
external storage has changed.
In KitKat, we actually
removed the need
to use the storage
permissions to read and write
those directories.
So if you were
targeting pre-KitKat,
you actually needed
those permissions,
even though they were
app-specific directories.
And we've listed that
restriction as of KitKat,
so now you no longer need that.
Awesome.
Now, that external user storage,
that public storage, that
always requires the
storage permission, right?
We very much want
users to be aware
that apps are writing to the
space that may potentially
be taking up a very large
percentage of their device's
space, but are not actually
attributed to that user.
If a user goes in says
clear data or clear cache,
those external files
are not deleted.
So a unless user is
using a file manager,
those files are not ever
going to be cleaned up.
And from the user's
perspective, they
might not know which
files go to which app
or which ones they can delete.
Now, the storage permission
is even more important
in Marshmallow because
in Marshmallow,
with the runtime
permissions model,
the storage permission
is considered
a dangerous permission.
That means if you're targeting
Marshmallow and running
on a 6.0 device,
you'll actually need
to request access to the
storage permissions at run time.
You get this nice, mildly scary
looking dialogue that says,
can they access all of
your photos and videos?
Everything you've ever done
in external storage, right?
Which yeah, that's true.
That's part of the user's
public external storage.
But you have to think really
long and hard of whether that's
actually the right choice.
Now, if you're
saying, well, I only
write to those
app-specific directories.
I'm good.
There's actually
a super easy way
to remove storage permissions.
You can use max SDK version.
Now, max SDK version just says,
I want to use this permission.
But as of KitKat, I
don't need it anymore.
I can safely remove
it from my manifest.
Users won't be bothered
by it at install time.
I don't need to worry about
it for runtime permissions.
You do this just by setting the
max SDK version in your user's
permission in the manifest.
And that's all you need to do to
remove the storage permission.
But still keep it
around for those cases
where you're running
on an older device.
But [? min ?] SDK KitKat?
That's not totally
unreasonable, right?
Maybe?
Maybe one day.
AUDIENCE: 21.
IAN LAKE: [? Min ?] SDK 21.
That's even better.
Now this isn't to actually
make your life more difficult,
but really to just make it so
that you can balance your needs
as a developer to save files to
a user's storage and their need
for privacy and
control, when really
giving your app the
storage permission
is asking for a lot of trust.
Those are all of the pictures,
all the videos that that person
has ever done on that device.
And sometimes those are a
little bit more sensitive.
And part of that is that
it's really all or nothing.
There's not necessarily that
requirement of saying, oh.
Well, I would really like access
to this specific directory
because of this all encompassing
nature of the storage
permission.
Now, part of this is just a
complexity kind of reason.
Users don't really understand
what kinds of storage
there are.
Like if you asked a
typical user, all right.
Out of these ten directories,
which four of them
would you like the app
to be able to read to?
That's a little bit harder
than just a yes or no kind
of an answer.
Now, the one thing
is that you really
want to avoid this, right?
That's the whole
reason we're here.
So let's talk through some away
is where we can really actually
get a lot of this functionality,
a lot of that communication
between apps, without actually
needing these permissions.
So what is this better way?
Is there a different
thing to do?
And it turns out that we have
a whole permissions model just
for sharing individual
files via URIs.
Now, a URI, you might think of
it as kind of like a file path.
But it's actually a
little bit different,
because you can apply
URI-based permissions to it.
Now, it really started back
in the beginning of Android
with our intent system.
That's the way of sending
information or calls
between different apps.
You may say like a start
activity and pass in an intent,
and that's how you would
then trigger another app
to do things.
These URI-based
permissions are attached
to that same infrastructure.
Allowing one app that
does have the permission
to access a file or
resource the ability
to then kind of forward, grant,
a permission to another app
that doesn't have
permission by itself.
But via that intent
system, they're
able to then suddenly
get permission
to just that specific file.
So this sounds like
exactly what we
need to do many of the
operations between files--
say, sharing or something else--
that we normally use files for.
So there's actually
two different ways
of using URI-based permissions.
One is just adding a simple flag
to your start activity or start
service intent.
And these flags just say, yeah,
any URI that's attached to this
can actually be read
by the receiving app
or even written to
by the receiving app.
So this could be
something, for example,
like you include an image URI
as well as the read permission.
Now all of a sudden,
the other app
can then read that image without
actually requiring access
to wherever that file
is actually stored.
In addition, you can
actually programmatically
grant and revoke
these permissions.
You can call grantUriPermission
with a specific package
and say, this package
is always good to read
any URI that's included.
Similarly, you can actually
revoke a URI permission.
So this would be
useful if like you're
deleting an internal file and
other apps have a URI to it.
You may want to revoke all
URI permissions to that file
just so that it
doesn't linger on.
So let's look at one of those
common examples, the Share
button that you've
seen hopefully
in many apps, the
actual Share button
not some fake share button.
And this is very
common for using, say,
sharing an image
from your camera
app to, say, a social media app.
Now if we were able to
use external storage,
the sending app might
write it to someplace
in a public directory.
And then the reading
app would then
need to have the read storage
permission to then read
the app.
And of course, this
will never work
in Android for Work scenarios
where the actual receiving
app and the sending app
are on two different users.
So maybe we can use
something else to actually
get this across.
And you'd think maybe, oh.
We just pass in our grant flag
and we pass in our file URI,
and we're golden.
One problem-- file
URIs don't work
with URI-based permissions.
File URIs are always protected
by the underlying storage
permissions.
You're directly
accessing a file,
and therefore you're going
through that file system which
is the storage permission.
So instead, we need to add just
a little bit of indirection
between our files
and the other app's.
And we can do that via
a Support.v4 library
class called FileProvider.
While this is built on top
of ContentProvider-- which
you may have heard of and
dislike or like in some cases--
you don't actually need to write
any ContentProvider code, which
is great.
There's actually
very little code
to actually write
in the FileProvider.
What this allows you
to do is actually
give apps access to files
in your getFiles directory,
your getCache directory,
or any of the get
external directories.
So these would be
places where you
can write without the
storage permission,
especially on KitKat and above.
But through FileProvider,
now other apps
can read those files.
That breaks the need for any
of the storage permission,
because what we are sending is a
URI and not a direct file path.
And that allows us to use
URI-based permissions.
Now, there is some set
up for FileProvider.
Specifically, every one
of those FileProvider URIs
has kind of a unique prefix,
which we'll call the authority.
Now, you can just define it
as a static string somewhere.
But I like to be a
little bit more fancy.
This is the limit of
my Gradle knowledge.
And actually define
it in our Gradle file
based on our application ID.
So this would be kind of the
package name in your app.
And we can actually define
it as a manifest placeholder.
So now we can actually use
it in our manifest file
without having to reference
the actual string.
And we can reference it in
our build config directories
if any of our Java classes.
And now it's always in sync.
We only have one
place to change it.
And if we have multiple
versions and build configs,
it just works.
So our manifest entry just
defines our file provider.
We're not writing
any code so far.
It's just a little bit of XML
that you can paste right in.
Because all of the
configuration is actually
done by the FileProvider's
path metadata.
So this metadata is just
a really simple XML file
that you put in your
res XML directory that
just says what directories
you're actually
providing through FileProvider.
What we don't want is
we don't want every app
to be able to read every file in
getFiles directory and getCache
directory.
You may want to just
have one directory
that you make available-- or,
in this case, three directories.
You can have it read from
the getFiles directory using
the files path, getCache
directory via the cache path,
and any of the get external
directories via external path.
And the path is kind of that
unique substring or subfolder
within those directories.
So that's all the
one time setup.
You only need to do that once
and then never touch it again,
no matter how many share buttons
you have throughout your app.
Now we can actually
share a file.
So just like before, we'll have
a file that we want to share.
And then we can just use one
method from FileProvider,
or get URI for file method.
And this takes in our
build config and the file
and then spits out a
special content URI.
We construct our share
intent, and then actually
provide read access by calling
set data with our content URI
and then adding the read flag.
Now, the important
thing to note here
is that that add flag of
grant read only applies,
in this case, to URIs
we've set in set data.
So if we leave out that
line, our grant flag
won't actually
apply to any URIs.
So it's really important
that those things kind of go
together in almost all cases.
On the receiving side,
we can extract the URI.
And then getting out the
actual data out of URI
has a very simple method,
get content resolver
openInputStream.
Now, the nice part
about openInputStream
is it works for practically
any URI you pass in,
whether it's one of our
FileProvider URI's, a file URI,
or an Android resource URI.
It's all the exact same code.
From your receiver's
perspective,
it shouldn't matter how
the sending app is sending
that file across,
because you can parse it
all in the same method.
So here, we just
use BitmapFactory
to extract a bitmap from it.
Now, the other thing
that's nice about this
is that you can actually daisy
chain those permissions along.
Say this is a
receiving activity,
but it's actually a
service that needs
to upload that file across.
You can call the same set data
and add the grant flag URI
to your start service,
and that permission
will continue to daisy chain
through different components--
or if you want to send
it to another app,
you can continue
to pass it along
as long as you continue
to use the grant flag URI.
Now, you may have noticed
the FileNotFoundException.
So here's where things
go horribly wrong.
But it's also the most
important part of sharing,
and that's cooperation.
It's a two-sided street.
There's a sending app and
there's a receiving app.
Like I said, a lot
of this relies on,
in this case, the sending app
to store it in the right place,
to use FileProvider so that
the receiving app doesn't
need the storage permission.
All right, if the sending
app isn't doing a good job,
it is writing it out
to a directory that
assumes that everyone
has read storage,
there's not actually
a whole lot you
can do here except have read
storage to read the file.
Now, many Google Apps
employ a strategy where,
if it fails, then post
a message saying, hey,
I can't read that file.
Like the other app
is trying to send me
something that I can't read.
Now, that definitely
pushes the requirement back
onto the sending app
to do it correctly.
So if you have a sending
app that's doing it wrong,
please fix it, because that's
breaking everyone else.
Now hopefully, apps are
testing with things like Gmail
and other apps that are
already installed on the system
to make sure that it works.
But at the same point,
you can actually
do that where we're setting
the onus on the sending app.
Now, you can take a
different approach.
Use that FileNotFoundException
as actually a requirement
to say, oh, let me get
the file permission.
Say you're running
on Marshmallow
and using runtime permissions.
Now, that works.
It would get the number
of shares up to a higher
percentage because you would
be able to then say, oh,
I don't have access to this.
Let me see if adding
storage permission
helps me work around
some of the bad apps
that we're all fixing,
like right now.
Yeah.
No?
OK.
We'll give it a
few more minutes.
So that's one way to do it.
But unfortunately, that means
that your app then appears
as using storage permission.
When you install the
app, it says, hey,
these guys are using
the storage permission.
Even in runtime model,
you need to have
a second dialog that pops up.
The users may not know, oh, well
I'm sharing a file over, right?
And this works for other apps.
But this app is
saying now it wants
to read all of my
photos and videos?
Like, I thought I
was just giving it
access to that one photo.
So you have to deal with
that different privacy model
where maybe it makes
more sense to say,
I don't want the
storage permission.
I want to say, well,
there's probably
a different app on your
phone that can give me
that same information.
Or maybe there are
some cases where
you can use a different
technique which actually
reverses the situation.
And that's ACTION_GET_CONTENT.
Now, GET_CONTENT's
kind of the reverse
where we're asking for a
file from a different app.
And you do this simply
by requesting it
by a MIME type-- say,
image slash star,
to get any kind of image.
I just want a picture.
Just give me
anything you've got.
And then you want to immediately
use that result in your app--
say, attach it to
an email or send it
to a friend via
messenger, what have you.
Now, much of the
logic here is actually
exactly the same as ACTION_SEND,
just in a reverse manner.
You'll call ACTION_GET_CONTENT,
passing in a request.
And then the providing app, the
one who the user has selected,
will use FileProvider.
Surprise, like who
would have guessed?
They'll use FileProvider,
get URI for file,
and then send that file
back to the requesting app.
And then openInputStream
to open the file, right?
Very similar, but just in
the kind of reverse model.
Now, note-- none of this code
requires a storage permission.
We're still asking from
one file to the other.
But it still works, right?
We're using URI-based
permissions.
And because the user is actively
included in the selection
process, there doesn't have
to be a blanket storage
permission.
Just by selecting, "I only
want to share these two
pictures" or something,
then the user knows, oh,
I'm giving this other app
access to these two pictures.
So we don't need a separate set
of permissions on top of this.
Now, the nice part
about GET_CONTENT
is you can actually do
it with multiple files.
So EXTRA_ALLOW_MULTIPLE
true, and all of a sudden,
assuming the providing
app supports it,
you can actually
select multiple files.
On the providing side, you can
actually add all these URIs
to what's called clip data.
So this was introduced
in API 16, that
allows you to have multiple URIs
covered by that same grant read
permission.
So before we had set
data for a single URI,
and now we have clip
data for multiple URIs.
Now, you may be
thinking, oh, API 16?
I support Gingerbread
because I hate myself.
Or I really love
my users, right?
There are lots of
Gingerbread users out there.
We love them too.
And it turns out that
EXTRA_ALLOW_MULTIPLE
was added in API 18, so not
a problem for this case.
In most cases, for
earlier APIs, they
didn't have a concept
of reading multiple URIs
until after API 16.
So in most cases, the
set data is actually
enough for the cases where
you're not on API 16.
So from our chart
at the beginning,
KitKat kind of changed
a lot of things.
It actually added a new action
call to ACTION_OPEN_DOCUMENT.
This is part of what we call the
storage access framework, which
is a really big, scary,
easy to Google name
if you need more
information about it.
But it works very similar to
ACTION_GET_CONTENT via API.
It's still intent.
It actually covers many of the
allow multiple and category
openable that we
saw for GET_CONTENT.
And of course, no
storage permissions
attached to any of the
storage access framework.
I wouldn't really
be talking about it
if it had storage permissions.
That would defeat the
whole purpose of my talk.
But what it does allow
you to do is actually
additional APIs is on
top of that GET_CONTENT
openInputStream kind
of API that we already
have through DocumentContract.
So here we have different APIs
of getting additional metadata
about files, when it
was last modified,
lots of good information
you'd expect from a file.
But we're not
providing file paths.
We're providing
access to documents.
And better yet,
all of these URIs
actually have the
ability to be persistent.
So it's not just a one time, oh,
I want to read this one file,
and then I have to
create a copy of it
and then keep a separate
copy for myself.
You can actually say, I want to
persist these URI permissions
from anything included from
the storage access framework.
That allows you
actually have a list
of things that go on forever,
or track what things you've
actually ever accessed.
So we supposed to just always
switch to OPEN_DOCUMENT?
Like everyone's running
KitKat, so we're fine.
Now, pre-KitKat, you don't
really have a choice.
It is still GET_CONTENT.
OPEN_DOCUMENT won't work.
You won't find any apps that
[? do it. ?] It doesn't exist.
But they really have
slightly different purposes.
So GET_CONTENT is that temporary
access to a file, to a URI.
So consider the case of
an image editing app.
GET_CONTENT could still be
used for importing clip art
or adding layers to an
existing editing session.
In that case, it
doesn't really matter
that you have direct
access to the file forever.
It's more that you want
to kind of at one time,
oh, I'm going to paste
this into the file,
but I don't want
the user to have
to pick from a predefined list.
I can use any file
on their device.
But for accessing the
image for our image apping,
we may want to
use OPEN_DOCUMENT,
because then we would
have persistent read
and write access to
that edited file.
This also allows us to actually
save the edits directly
to the file, overriding
it, actually saving it
where the user expects to find
the file at a later point--
which is great, because if
you've ever done editing that
has different copies,
you'll somehow never
find that edited photo
ever again if you actually
look for it.
But if you have
OPEN_DOCUMENT, now you
can actually save it
directly over the file.
You can also do
really cool things.
Like, say your editor
wants a recently used list
when you open it up.
Like, let me show you the last
five images that you edited.
Well, if you've persisted
access to those URIs,
now you can have a
list of all the images
that you've had recently without
having to figure out, OK.
Well, the user selected
this file from somewhere,
let me hope it's there.
I can just use the URI
that I already have.
Now, one thing is that if
that file that they selected
something from was uninstalled--
or, say, the image was removed
from the source app-- then when
you call give me the URI again,
it's not going to
return anything.
The file is gone, right?
That's the whole reason
behind the URI thing.
But in many cases, that's
exactly what you want, right?
You don't necessarily want,
from a user perspective,
for them to say, oh, I
deleted this from my gallery.
But there's still that
app that has a copy of it,
and that app has
another copy of it.
And then that second
app doesn't even
have a delete
button or anything.
So now I have this data that I
don't really want on my device.
But in fact, OPEN_DOCUMENT
also allows document providers
to provide delete
access to other files.
You may not even need to
go back into the gallery
and delete the app if
you're using OPEN_DOCUMENT.
You may actually be able
to delete it directly
from that app and say,
oh, well, you know what?
Like, I don't think we
actually need this file.
Now, you will
probably want to check
to make sure you actually have
delete access before trying
to just delete users' files.
It may not always be the case.
But there's one thing to
be sure-- OPEN_DOCUMENT
is just better.
So it provides all of the same
functionality as GET_CONTENT,
in addition to this
new functionality
we've talked
about-- and frankly,
a lot more functionality.
So when you call
OPEN_DOCUMENT, you're
only going to get apps that
support ACTION_OPEN_DOCUMENT,
that have a document provider,
the class that they would need,
on their side.
Now, this means that you may get
a more limited number of apps.
But obviously, when you're
using OPEN_DOCUMENT,
maybe you're expecting that
persistence or those new APIs.
However, if you're on KitKat and
above and you call GET_CONTENT,
you'll actually get both.
You'll get all of the apps that
support GET_CONTENT as well
as all the apps that
support OPEN_DOCUMENT,
because anything you
can do with GET_CONTENT
can also be done
on a document URI
that you've retrieved
via OPEN_DOCUMENT--
the same opening, the same
checking things on either one.
Now, this does allow us to do
some optionally cool things.
There's actually a document
contract is document URI.
So you can check to see if
your return result is actually
a document URI.
And then you can
use those new APIs.
And if they've
selected something
from a GET_CONTENT app, then you
can just use just the default
functionality.
Now, the nice part is
that even though you're
getting these URIs, you can use
a document file class, which
is part of the Android
Support Library v4,
which kind of gives
you a very similar API
to a file for a document URI.
So you can check, do
I have read access?
Do I have write access?
Do I have delete access?
All in a very simple API, and
use it simultaneously for files
and simultaneously
for these document
URIs, which is really nice.
Very handy.
Now, that does
mean that if you're
an app that supports GET_CONTENT
and you support OPEN_DOCUMENT,
you need to disable your
GET_CONTENT on API 19
and above.
Otherwise, users will
see GET_CONTENT one
in the list and your storage
provider in the same list.
So you disable one and
say, well, OPEN_DOCUMENT
can do everything
that GET_CONTENT does,
so I'll just have that
appear in the list.
You no longer need GET_CONTENT
if you're using OPEN_DOCUMENT.
So what does accessing the
storage access framework
look like from a
user's perspective?
So from their
perspective, they're
in an app-- say,
our Photo Editor.
And they hit the button
saying, get me a file.
Well, unlike GET_CONTENT,
where they have to pick an app
and then go into that app and
have some custom UI where they
select things and then that app
doesn't support multi-select
and then they're clicking on
one and hitting load and then
clicking on a second
one and hitting load,
all of the UI for
storage access framework
is done by the system.
You don't need to write any UI
to support the storage access
framework.
You can just do just
the data part of things.
So this is really
nice, because then when
the new version of
Android comes out,
you get even more
functionality for free.
You don't have to say,
oh, I'm going to support
this new stuff as much.
Because what's
happening is the system
is the one who's reading
from the document providers
and giving new functionality.
So for example, in KitKat and
above, coming with the system
you get internal storage,
a document provider
provided by the system.
As well as if you plugged
in a removable hard drive
or something, you'd actually
get a document provider
for that removable hard
drive automatically.
As soon as you unplugged
it, that document provider
would disappear.
It's great.
Now people can
select those files.
In Marshmallow, we've
extended that, so now
when you have an SD card,
you can do the same thing,
and the storage provider
will just instantly appear
for the SD card.
So now all of a sudden, you
can get write, read, and read
directory access to the SD card
for practically the first time
ever.
So we mentioned our
ACTION_OPEN_DOCUMENT
for accessing a document.
Now, I keep calling
it a document.
It's not necessarily a
file on your local storage.
It could be piped directly
across from the internet.
It could be in an encrypted
blob on a specific hard drive.
It doesn't particularly matter,
because from the readings app
perspective, all you're getting
is an input stream or a file
descriptor that then you can
stream the contents from.
And all the metadata
is handled separately.
So you'll also get
some other new ones.
ACTION_CREATE_DOCUMENT
is kind of
like the Save button
in an app, right?
Where instead of
you saying, oh, I'm
just going to save it
to this one directory
that the user knows no
idea of where that is,
they can instead save
it to Google Drive
or save it to their
removable storage.
It doesn't actually matter where
they save it, because again,
you'll have access to that URI.
You can get back to
that file at any point.
This is very
different from the, I
want to save it always
in this one directory.
Now users can use
different storage providers
and switch between them.
And then, if they want
to select a file that
may be on a different device,
they saved it to Google Drive.
You go on to their
other drive, now
they can OPEN_DOCUMENT,
select Google Drive,
and suddenly get
access to that file
without you having to
integrate with any SDKs
or do any extra work because
storage access framework
kind of separates you from where
the files are actually stored.
Now, my personal favorite
was added in Lollipop.
And that's OPEN_DOCUMENT_TREE.
So this, instead of giving
access to an individual file,
now you get access to
a whole document tree-
or let's call it just a folder,
because that's a nice name.
You get access to the whole
folder and all of its children.
Right, so in this
case, you can actually
say like, oh, well, where
do you want me to save
these backups of your app?
And you can say, well, I want
to store them on Google Drive,
and give them access to just
one particular folder-- not
your entire Google Drive,
because that's maybe
a little scary and
terabytes of data, maybe?
But just one directory.
And then throughout the
entire lifetime of your app,
you can then read and
write to that directory
without additionally
bothering the user with,
oh, hey-- where did you want
me to put this file every time?
You can have a default
save location for new edits
that could go into this file.
The choices are really very
limitless when you're actually
in that kind of setting.
So implementing a
DocumentProvider,
kind of a few methods.
Not any ContentProvider
methods, even
though it's actually
a ContentProvider
underneath the covers.
You'll notice we do that a lot.
Because ContentProviders are
really great at providing URIs
to other systems, it's how we
do communication between devices
or between apps.
Instead, you'll implement
four methods-- queryRoots,
which is kind of the
top level like, I
am an app that provides storage
access framework controls.
And this is my name.
I want to be called
Google Drive.
That's a good name for
the app, Google Drive.
Now normally, you
just have one root.
But you can actually
return multiple roots.
Say if you're logged
into multiple users
at the same time, you could
have different accounts in here
so that the user, without
having to go into your app
and select an account and
then select which file,
they would just
appear as top level
directories in the storage
access framework UI.
Now, queryChildDocuments
and queryDocuments
are kind of what you
expect-- information
about all the things within
a folder and information
about a particular document.
And then openDocuments,
really kind of the main key
is the give me the bytes,
gives me the information
about this file, right?
And it may just be
loading the file itself,
or it may be doing
something totally
different like streaming
it across the internet
and opening up a socket
that persists forever.
And that's the thing.
From the app's perspective,
it doesn't matter, right?
From someone who's
reading it in-- again,
it doesn't particularly
matter what the API is doing.
It's just that OPEN_DOCUMENT
exists, and suddenly it works.
So there's actually
quite a few resources
about implementing it, if
you're one of those things who
run Dropbox or Box
or Google Drive
or really anything you want.
There's information on
developer.android.com.
I've built a sample app called
LocalStorage which gives you
kind of both a simple UI to
test out all of these actions
that we've talked about as well
as give you a sample storage
provider which you
can build upon.
And then Jeff Sharkey, the
storage framework engineer
who's responsible for
just about all this stuff,
wrote an example provider called
Vault, which actually encrypts
all the files and
then auto decrypts it
when you use them
in storage provider.
So very nice example
of going a little bit
beyond just a
simple OPEN_DOCUMENT
opens the file
underneath the covers.
So to recap, what do we need
the storage permission for?
Accessing our internal
app's specific directories?
Nope, nothing there.
External apps or
apps-specific directories?
Not above Lollipop.
So we can use max SDK 18.
For sending files
via ACTION_SEND?
No, we've got FileProvider.
We're good.
For receiving files
or requesting files
from other apps?
No, not if everyone's
doing their job right.
But if you really do want to
have that fallback of asking
for the storage permission,
really, really consider,
at most, max SDK 22.
Don't specifically ask
for storage permissions
on runtime permissions model
just because you want access
to one file.
In theory, hopefully
Marshmallow will kind of
push apps to be a little
bit better in this range,
because really we want
everyone to be playing nicely.
They don't need access to every
one of the photos and videos
that you guys have shot,
especially if they're
videos from Big Android BBQ.
Don't share any of those ones.
You know the ones
I'm talking about.
But really, we want to
make the storage permission
the exception, right?
If you booted up a
Marshmallow phone
and you look at the
number of permissions,
you'll note that storage
permission is generally
the highest one in count,
and I would rather it
be the lowest one in count.
Because really, that means
that those apps, unless you're
a specific app
like File Explorer
or something like
that that needs access
to all those files, you
probably don't actually
need access to all of them.
So we've actually
done a lot of work
on that even
internally in Google.
Like runtime permissions are
still a really big deal inside
of Google as well.
So for example, the next release
of Google Maps Android's SDK
is removing storage entirely.
No longer needed the storage
permission to run any
the Maps stuff, which
previously they were using.
And even right now
in 8.1, you don't
need the storage permission
on Marshmallow devices.
So there's actually a lot of
documentation on the Google
Maps site that tells you exactly
when those things are happening
and will surely be updated when
the next version of Google Play
services comes out.
So thank you all for your time.
My name's Ian Lake.
You can catch me on
Google+ or Twitter.
Happy to help at all times.
So I'll be down
here for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]